es momento de economía este 11 de
noviembre aquí en france 24 y por ello
recibo con muchísimo gusto daniel
hablando ramírez la especialista
económica daniela en eeuu revivió el
caso tick tock a las muy buenas noches
recordemos que en agosto donald trump
perdió un plazo de 90 días para que la
empresa sea vendida o de lo contrario
tendrá que suspender sus operaciones en
este país este jueves vence ese plazo
pues son matrices la china byd de hans
pidió al tribunal de apelaciones del
distrito de columbia una prórroga de al
menos 30 días con eso podrá sellar un
acuerdo que está negociando con walmart
y con oracle también dijo que si no se
le concede el plazo acudir a otras
instancias para defender sus derechos la
polémica tiene que ver con que la
administración trump plantea problemas
de seguridad para los 100 millones de
usuarios de 'tik tok' en su país pero
china lo niega rotundamente
la onu llamó la atención daniela por el
alto costo del embarazo adolescente en
américa latina' en investigaciones del
fondo de población de naciones unidas en
6 países reveló que el embarazo
adolescente en la región les cuesta a
los gobiernos un promedio de mil 242
millones de dólares anuales o 10 35% del
producto interno bruto y agrega que esta
situación agrava la pobreza y la
desigualdad esta cifra corresponde al
costo de oportunidad es decir alan lo
que cada estado tiene que destinar
anualmente por los embarazos de niñas de
entre 10 y 19 años colombia y paraguay
lideran estos costos para ver qué países
son los más afectados es más preciso
medirlo como porcentaje del pib alan
porque si se compara en dólares los que
tienen más habitantes como por ejemplo
méxico estarían a la cabeza y sería
distinto el dato américa latina tiene la
segunda tasa de embarazo adolescente más
elevada del mundo con más de 15 millones
de madres al año
seguimos en américa latina y es que en
brasil se comienza a recuperar el
comercio minorista daniela
por la pandemia si la actividad de
comercio minorista está recuperándose de
las drásticas caídas registradas en la
época más dura de la pandemia las ventas
tuvieron un alza récord del 17 2% en el
tercer trimestre del año como vemos en
el gráfico esto frente al segundo
trimestre después de haber caído en los
dos primeros trimestres 1,9 y 8,5 por
ciento respectivamente lo que más llama
la atención de las autoridades
económicas es la rápida recuperación que
han tenido algunos sectores como
vehículos motocicletas repuestos
textiles y calzado hoy daniela el
gobierno de grecia busca profesionales
para que se vayan a vivir a ese país
miremos a ver si le interesa este a
través de escucho grecia se vio muy
golpeado durante la crisis de deuda que
comenzó en 2009 y más de 800 mil griegos
se fueron a ejercer sus profesiones en
otros países pues el gobierno quiere
llevarlos de vuelta pero no solamente a
ellos también a los profesionales de
otras nacionaliza nacionalidades que
quieran instalarse allá para frenar la
fuga masiva de talentos
mejor manera de conquistar los es con
incentivos fiscales a finales de este
año será llevado un proyecto de ley al
parlamento para que quienes migran a
grecia declaren impuestos sobre la mitad
y no sobre todos los ingresos que
perciben durante siete años el 'break'
sitel también hará parte de este plan si
todo sale como lo planea el gobierno
habrá un incentivo fiscal adicional para
las personas que se devuelvan del reino
unido tras su salida de la unión europea
no suena mal hagamos ahora un recorrido
de los indicadores económicos por el
mundo bueno wall street tercero mixto en
una jornada impulsada por las
tecnológicas el índice compuesto nasdaq
subió más del 2 por ciento las bolsas
europeas siguen de fiesta por tercer día
consecutivo esperanzadas en que pronto
habrá una vacuna contra el comité aunque
esta noticia tuvo un ganador particular
alan y le voy a decir de quién se trata
el show the fighter albert de burla
vendió el 62 por ciento de las acciones
que tenían esta compañía el mismo día
que se hizo el anuncio esto le permitió
poner en su cuenta la no despreciable
suma de 56 millones de dólares
y en américa latina la bolsa de brasil
cortó una racha de sesiones consecutivas
al alza cerramos con la cifra el día en
días como a 8 % subió la tasa de ahorro
de los hogares en los 27 países de la
unión europea esto en el segundo
trimestre de 2020 y se debe a que el
consumo bajo en todos los países
subieron los ahorros de los ciudadanos
menos en suecia los países más viciosos
con el ahorro son irlanda y españa bueno
pues con la pandemia no daniela muchas
gracias por este recorrido económico y
ustedes por su compañía ya lo sabe vea
más mucho más en france24
[Música]